pascal n'abîme pas ton show et appel
vous allez voir comme les gens sont
méchants
maintenant je mange et avec mademoiselle
long bec
elle peut pas boire je ne peux pas boire
en pleine répétition elle m'a dit
monsieur fermoir vous chantez faut
savoir pourquoi vous avez fait une
fausse pub
j'ai moi je sais ce que c'était c'est
une sacrée histoire en ouvrant la porte
elle avait crise et on leur a fait un
cru que c'était moi nantes s'est
empressé de dire monsieur l'abbé qu'est
ce qu'il ya comme grands si si jamais
j'ai eu une faux je finirai jamais ça ce
matin
vous allez voir comme les gens sont
méchants
je passais traverser la rue il ya une
vie n'a pas nar qui arrive à mes jeux
travers dans les plots il ya en plein
dedans
il a eu la jambe sélectionné c'est
normal bien heureusement qu'il y avait
du pdci glace encore alors faire des
renault c'est ça vaut distraction du
dimanche
bah oui voyage eux
je faucher je raconte des histoires
c'est pour ça que vous parler tout seul
ouais ça m'arrive souvent c'est pour ça
il d'ailleurs qu' il ya des arbres tout
autre mon genre là à cause des voisins
édition les fous il parle tout seul ça
m'arrive souvent aussi dans le métro je
me surprends près tout seul alors
maintenant je me cache dans la verdure
mais vous n'avez pas que ça comme
distraction le dimanche
non ben alors je joue aux cartes
j'aime bien la musique aussi la musique
vous jouez d'un instrument
oui je joue du téléphone ou encore en
restant sérieux j'aime bien la musique
classique par exemple le prélude de
rachmaninoff barousse
j'aime bien chauffer visite dont fernand
est ce que vous pourriez donner à nos
téléspectateurs un petit aperçu de vos
talents de pianiste de virtuoses en nous
je crois que je l'aimé c'est vrai enfin
moi je veux bien essayer mais pas
longtemps là
aussi tant qu'un morceau classique
de la fin du xviiie siècle la morceau
d'espagnols qui peut jouer car il faut
une certaine dextérité vous dis pas que
j'ai réussir aimer vraiment possible
aujourd'hui c'est spécial qui sont nés
entre amis un morceau qui s'intitule les
oranje
on
à
e
les oranje espagnol et maintenant je
vous fais un tour deux cas si vous
permettez parce que le dimanche
j'aime bien faire des tours 4 même des
heures oui alors vous prenez un jeu de
cartes qui ne soit pas truqué parce que
si c'est truqué sanaa beaucoup moins de
valeur quoi alors vous prenez beaucoup
des 4 as me t4 à ce que j'ai préparé et
que je met dessus sur chacun de ces as
vous mettez un paquet quatre cartes
qu'elle qu'on croyait
et si d'autre que les quatre pas qu'ils
vont être faits vous mettez un as dessus
voyez regardez bien parce qu'après vous
direz c'est pas vrai innovant il les a
pas mis dessus et je vous assure je vous
donne ma parole comme on dit enfin que
le jeu de cartes n'est pas truquée ouais
donc sur chacun de ces paquets llanas je
prends ce paquet s'il l'a si bien
toujours dessus c'est bien toujours 4,4
quelconque voilà et je compte ont
regardé mais 1 2 3 et les 4
elle a alors la queue en général vos
amis disent tiens c'est étonnant parce
qu'on voit plus la ce des fois il ya des
gens ils s'en fichent sa porte pas du
tout vous voyez 4k
las dessus et georges jammes refait
devants aux sénateurs de garde que la
paix n'est qu'après un deux trois
vous faites cela certains ça fait
dextérité oui ça fait deux lacs et au
courant et je toujours là dessus il faut
toujours montrer alors il ya des
personnes qui sont sceptiques
un deux trois quatre derniers voile
alors je joue le faire bloc marveaux
ralenti un jeu nous avons ralenti parce
que parce qu'on est des années toujours
dessus d'eux regardez bien oi et un ans
voilà vous ramassez comme ceux ci les
paquets du tout les paquets sont
ramassés vous avons fait lot et sitôt
que les cinq paquets ont été faits je
vous pose une question à vous
téléspectateurs
on va jouer à un jeu franc mais un deux
trois quatre cinq paquets montrez-moi un
paquet au hasard les dix que le oui 1 2
3 4 5
dites-moi chiffres au hasard à l'équipe
le fort vous l'avez dit c'est ça ne nous
avait rien n'est gagné
c'est bien 3 merci les 4 as senti si
mais si vous avez les 10,2 c'était fichu
là je sais moi qui aurait perdu et ouais
on n'aurait pas pris voilà c'est vous
qui gagnez et eni et maintenant pascal
je vais faire à notre tour maintenant
celui-ci l'effort pascal
eh bien en attendant mon copain pascal
fait je vous laisse t il c'est très
simple dès les 4 cartes comme ça quand
vous mettez l'as du sud et de l'est joue
le sahara l'envers pour bien vous
montrer
il ya un truc forcément comme dans tous
les tours hawaiian on verra ce que ça
donne j'enlève une carte 1
mais alors voyez quand je pose la
deuxième la regardez bien ce douanes à
ce qu'il fait il fait ceci l'a si bien
que je prends les deux autres à la fois
et derrière gallas qui s'arrogent sans
être vu si bien quand vous posez la
carte comme ceux ci on ne voit pas la ce
et je pense 4k et tous demandé c'était
pas tant alors que là s'il est gâchée
derrière mais vous dirai pas aux autres
ça sortirait que des bines les trucs à
mais voilà mon copain pascal vague à
gimont coppens et c'est mon meilleur
client en tout cas c'est mon fils mais
un peu à peu arriérée il va avoir 15
mois me fait pas sans heurts du tout
beaulieu
berné les vitraux un peu des deux il ne
s'est même pas le mien a + b au cube à 3
g ball et bien regardez je n'aidais il
fait celui qui comprend pas à 3 + 2a 2b
plus deux années de plus mais je vais
faire un tocard
regardez oui bah tiens regarde dessous
est alors maintenant je fais interne car
l'as de coeur oui on a beaucoup regardé
mais là c'est clair tiens une cape
n'importe laquelle celle que tu veux il
n'ya pas d'importance tu souhaites avait
dit tu permets pas de pause à une trame
15 mois et se laissent de coeur